[Música]
y díaz sigue con cifras récord de kobe
19 en el último día superó los 400 mil
nuevos casos al tiempo que inició su
etapa de vacunación para los mayores de
18 años hasta ahora se han inoculado 26
millones de ciudadanos una gota de agua
entre 600 millones que son aptos para
ser inyectados
en brasil un grupo de indígenas mattis
viajó hasta la ciudad de tabatinga
fronteriza con colombia para vacunarse
contra el hobbit 19 los habitantes que
normalmente se mantienen aislados en lo
profundo de las zonas tuvieron que
desplazarse por vías en canoa para
recibir la dosis pero ahora no tienen
recursos para volver a casa
y en colombia tras varios días de paro
nacional contra el proyecto de ley de
reforma tributaria del presidente iván
duque se dio y anunció cambios en el
texto que subía impuestos a los
servicios públicos funerarios y a la
canasta familiar pese al reclamo
ciudadano el gobierno dice que necesita
cerrar el hueco financiero de la
pandemia
una feliz mañana de sábado mi nombre es
ángela gómez y aquí comienzan las
noticias de france 24 iniciamos el
informativo en india que por primera vez
desde el inicio de la pandemia reportó
400.000 nuevos positivos en una sola
jornada en la segunda ola de kobe 19 el
país asiático está sobrepasado por el
virus pese a ser uno de los mayores
productores de vacunas del mundo ya se
han vacunado 26 millones de ciudadanos y
hoy inició la fase de inoculación para
mayores de 18 años pero en total hay 600
millones de de aptos para recibir el
medicamento lo que deja el territorio en
una situación de escasez de dosis india
tiene en total 19 como 1 millones de
contagios y se acerca a los 212 mil
fallecidos
una campaña más grande del mundo
empiezan unas 600 millones de personas
en india son aptas para recibir una
vacuna contra el coi 19 el proceso de
inoculación ha tenido un lento inicio
estamos completamente preparados
nuestros trabajadores sanitarios están
listos para la campaña pero no tenemos
vacuna del niño india produce dosis
desarrolladas por astrazéneca y su
propia vacuna kovacsics pero varios
estados han advertido que no tienen
suficientes inyecciones el gobierno
indio ha dicho que ha invertido
masivamente para acelerar la producción
pero con un promedio de 75 millones de
dosis producidas cada mes tomaría años
inocular a toda la población adulta unas
940 millones de personas las compañías
farmacéuticas acusan a eeuu de acaparar
el suministro de materias primas
enfrentando una escasez aguda los
centros de vacunación han estado
cerrados alrededor del país
fernando le estamos pidiendo a la gente
de karnataka especialmente a quienes
tienen entre 18 y 44 años que se
abstengan de ir a hospitales pensando
que serán vacunados todos hostels
thinking that you me vibra con el dedo
presenta mientras india lucha en el peor
momento del brote docenas de países han
ofrecido ayuda enviando cilindros de
oxígeno y otros suministros médicos para
los hospitales abarrotados pero en medio
de una ola de solidaridad otros
gobiernos también han restringido los
viajes a india eeuu ha anunciado que a
los extranjeros que lleguen de indian no
se les permitirá la entrada mientras que
australia suspendió todos los vuelos
advirtiendo que los ciudadanos que no
cumplan podrían enfrentar una sentencia
de cinco años de cárcel desde el
interior de la selva del amazonas
brasileño 35 miembros de la comunidad
indígena matthysse viajaron en canoas
durante varios días con el fin de
vacunarse contra el coronavirus esta
comunidad vive prácticamente aislada del
mundo exterior pero aún así el virus
supone una gran amenaza y tienen miedo
de que un brote pueda diezmar los
después de llegar a la frontera con
colombia ahora se encuentran atrapados
porque no cuentan con los recursos para
retornar a sus aldeas marinas ardilla
nos amplía esta noticia
doce días en río para conseguir el
preciado suero contra el hobbit 19 desde
sus aldeas en la profundidad de la selva
amazónica brasileña fronteriza con
colombia y perú más de 35 miembros de la
remota comunidad indígena matisse
dejaron sus malocas subidos en una
barcaza de madera viajaron hasta atalaya
do norte el pueblo más cercano para
recibir la segunda dosis de la vacuna 49
para la ciudad mi pariente viene de la
aldea [__] sí misma algunos tienen para
vacunarse otros vienen para arreglar la
documentación de sus hijos documentos
que necesitan para la bolsa de familia
maternidad todo eso
los equipos de vacunación no han podido
acceder a sus remotas aldeas en las
pasadas campañas de inoculación muchos
hombres de la comunidad se encontraban
cazando pescando por lo que no
recibieron las dosis ante el miedo a
contraer la enfermedad que dejan más de
mil indígenas muertos por el virus en
brasil decidieron tomar la iniciativa y
salir al exterior en busca de la vacuna
llevando consigo sus artesanías locales
para costearse el viaje de vuelta a la
selva
no sabemos qué está pasando afuera pero
así nosotros conseguimos gasolina para
poder retornar a la aldea nosotros no
dependemos de la funai ni de la sesa y
nosotros vamos rebuscando vamos
consiguiendo dinero de a poquito así
vamos consiguiendo solventar para
regresar a la aldea eso hacemos
si bien la remota comunidad matiz no ha
registrado ningún caso de kobe 19 entre
sus miembros a finales de 1976 cuando
fueron contactados por el exterior por
primera vez el 3 por ciento de la
población mattis murió a causa de varias
epidemias como la malaria o la gripe
ahora la muerte de sus chamanes o la
pérdida de tierras amenaza con diezmar
su comunidad y seguimos en américa
latina' colombia ha tenido una semana
agitada tras el paro nacional que inició
el 28 de abril en contra del proyecto de
reforma tributaria del gobierno el
presidente de iván duque anunció que se
modificará el texto de 110 páginas que
ha generado todo tipo de reacciones por
imponer tributos a los servicios
públicos y a la canasta familiar entre
otros
los que se oponen reclaman que se retire
todo el proyecto de ley pero el gobierno
alega que necesita subsanar el hueco
fiscal creado por la pandemia el informe
es de andrea amaya
el gobierno colombiano empieza a acceder
y propone cambios a la reforma
tributaria el presidente iván duque
ordenó al ministerio de hacienda a
construir junto con el congreso un nuevo
texto del polémico proyecto de ley con
el que busca recaudar cerca de 6 mil 302
millones de dólares para aliviar un
déficit fiscal la reforma no será
retirada pero se le harán cambios en los
puntos más álgidos que han desatado
protestas ciudadanas como el cobro del
iva a los servicios públicos impuestos
sobre el valor agregado que desde el 19%
que no van a haber aumentos en el iva en
bienes en servicios ni tampoco cambiar
las reglas de juego actuales en el país
eso quiere decir que en materia de iva
no va a haber entre otros
iva adicional o aumentos del iva a
productos y servicios que no se tocara
la canasta básica familiar de los
colombianos que no habrá iva a los
servicios públicos que no habrá iba a la
gasolina no se ampliará la base gravable
el mandatario colombiano agregó
las personas que actualmente no pagan el
impuesto de renta no lo harán segundo
que el proyecto busca ante todo
estabilizar las finanzas públicas y
proteger la calificación crediticia que
tiene colombia sin embargo a pesar de
una fuerte tercera ola de kobe 19 miles
de colombianos salieron a las calles
desde el miércoles para exigir el retiro
del proyecto consideran que afectará el
bolsillo de muchas personas con más
impuestos a la clase baja y media ya
duramente afectada por los estragos
económicos de la pandemia en este clima
de rechazo se suma el descontento por
los efectos sociales que ha tenido la
crisis sanitaria por kobe 19 que se ha
cobrado la vida de más de 73 mil
personas y que ha aumentado los niveles
de pobreza que según los más recientes
reportes subió al 42,5 por ciento en
pero el anuncio de los cambios en la
reforma tributaria en colombia no ha
calmado los ánimos en las calles en el
suroccidente del país en las ciudades de
cali y pasto hay un amplio despliegue
militar y allí las manifestaciones se
extendieron hasta la noche hay reportes
de desmanes por parte de algunos de los
manifestantes y en cali se habla hasta
de siete muertos y disparos con munición
letal por parte de la policía el
director de la institución dice que
hasta el momento no han encontrado
información concreta al respecto
y en afganistán se incrementó la
seguridad en la ciudad de kabul en
preparación para las posibles reacciones
violentas por parte de los insurgentes
talibanes a medida que las tropas
estadounidenses inician la fase final de
retirada del país por orden del
presidente joe by de una mayor presencia
militar y seguridad en los puntos de
control fueron visibles en la capital
afgana y una fuente de seguridad es dijo
que la ciudad había sido puesta en
alerta máxima entretanto este jueves
hubo 27 fallecidos y más de 60 heridos
tras la explosión de un carrobomba en la
provincia de logar el ataque dejó además
edificios destruidos y daños en el
principal hospitales de la zona y las
autoridades atribuyen la responsabilidad
al grupo talibán
hasta aquí el informativo usted recuerde
que puede seguirnos también en france24
punto com con actualizaciones de todas
las noticias por nuestro equipo
periodístico siga con nosotros y nos
vemos en minutos buenos días
[Música]